so
let's let's talk a bit about um
selecting the tuning parameter for ridge
regression and the lasso
first point is that's important uh the
lambda very strongly determines the
solution right
over a broad spectrum when lambda is
zero we get full least squares there's
no regularization
when labs infinity we get a zero
solution in both cases so
choosing lambda is extremely important
and cross-validation is the weight is
is a good technique for doing that note
also that we couldn't use the other
methods
because the d isn't known what other
methods am i talking about cp and aic
and bic
they all require a number of parameters
d
and it's not clear what what d is now
that's actually something interesting to
think about suppose i've
well suppose i fit a i've done a ridge
regression with i started with 45
variables like in the credit data
i've i use a certain lambda
let's go back to that just so i can
point at something an example
here's our ridge example suppose i
decide to use the lambda
of of a hundred right and
i'm here and ask you well what's the d
for that model how many parameters have
i fit well if i count the number of
parameters the number of non-zero
coefficients it's still
the the full number 11 right because
none of the coefficients are zero so in
a sense
all of my variables are still there so
my my d
number of parameters is still is still p
11. but that doesn't somehow seem right
right because i've shrunk in the
coefficients so they're not fully
they're not the number of degrees of
freedom isn't it isn't it as large so
there's a bit of a subtle point here the
number of parameters is not just
how many parameters i've used but how i
fit them right so with ridge regression
and lasso the shrinkage actually affects
the very idea of what we mean by number
of parameters
so that was a long way of saying that
for selecting the
tuning parameter for ridge regression
and lasso it's really important to use a
method that doesn't require
the value of d because it's hard to know
what d is
so cross validation fits the bill
perfectly
we do exactly what we did for the other
methods for
for uh for subset selection for example
we divide the data up into k parts
we fit the model let's say k equals 10.
we fit the model on nine parts
say we we apply
ridge regression for for a whole range
of lambdas
for the nine parts and then we we record
the error on the tenth part
we do that in turn for all ten parts
playing the role of the validation set
and then we add up all the errors
together and we get it we get a cross
validation curve as a function of lambda
same for the lasso so conceptually it's
exactly the same as we
as crossfire is exactly the same as we
applied it in the other in for other
methods
so let's see what it looks like here for
for ridge regression
here's here's a result of of cross
validation
i'm not sure if it's either 5 or 10 full
we can check here's cross validation as
a function of lambda
again remember lambda equals small means
essentially the least squares model
fully squares over here
and lambda equals large
means the coefficient has been driven to
0. so this is the cross validation error
as a function
of lambda and the minimum is occurring
around here around 0.05
here's this here's the same same thing
now but
we plot plotted as a function of lambda
the standardized coefficient so
this is
here the coefficients for each of the
predictors
their profiles and we see how they vary
as a function of lambda
so again over here there's full least
squares
and here they've been as we move to the
right they're shrunken
and at the minimum value of the curve
this broken line we get
a bunch of guys which are essentially
zero
but not exactly zero because this is
ridge not lasso and then here are the
the coefficients for the three active
variables
um
and here's for the this is our this is
the
simulated data with n equals 50 i think
there were two or three truly nonzero
coefficients in the population
for the last so this is now the
the result of cross validation
so
we've plotted the cross validation error
versus the the l1 norm of the lasso
solution divided by the l1 norm of the
full least square solution that's just
to give you a convenient way of scaling
the x axis so that
it goes from zero to one right the full
least squares estimates
give us a value of one
and zero estimates of zero give you a
value of zero and in between we have the
the intermediate lasso solutions so
here's the cross validation curve again
it's got that u shape that daniella
mentioned before
and it's minimum is it around
here about point point one
which is quite severe shrinkage which is
good here right because we know that the
true model has only three non-zero
coefficients and i think it's actually
two even better
okay two nonzero coefficients um and we
very good because here we seem to pick
up exactly two non-zero coefficients the
green and the red and the rest are
exactly zero so it's in this
um made up example it's done exactly the
right thing it's from the
correct two non-zero features and set
everything else exactly equal to zero